I have bare feet because I'm an old
hippie and I'm really nervous
hello Singapore what a charming place it
is it's my first time here I'm making
over 25 years a tour of all of Southeast
Asia so I just have Myanmar and Myanmar
and China to go now so thank you for
having me great food nice hotel I am
going to talk a lot so I'm going to do
it fast try not to fall asleep if you do
just ask me what you missed afterwards
buy me a beer tell me how much better I
am than Jake Archibald and it'd all be
good my talk is called if you're going
out of San Francisco the be sure to wear
web standards in your hair as I've said
I'm an old hippie and I made this slide
myself I'm available for freelance
design work if anybody needs me I'm here
to talk about war and peace I'm a hippie
I love peace peace guys I'm not talking
about you know huge devastating clashes
of civilizations I'm talking about you
know not not the really really important
things like this guy's icons I I fix
them for him yes we can talk later about
that I'm talking about holy wars holy
wars are kind of doctrinal clashes
between different sects of a religion
like Catholicism and Protestantism or
Shia and
that matter greatly hello man with a
camera mattered greatly to the people
involved but to people outside its
really really incomprehensible I'm
talking about the kind of big questions
like Beatles or all the stones or big
macs or whoppers or Iron Maiden
or proper music sorry Jake we've had
many many wholly web wars ie versus
Netscape tables versus CSS jQuery versus
vanilla JavaScript angular versus embarr
and the vs. react all these kind of
things and there's a new holy war that I
am hoping to help solve today so we can
actually get away from holy wars and
factor on focus on the important things
the current holy war is about how to do
styling in component-based development
so one side says CSS is completely
unsuitable for styling modern web
applications and CSS in j/s is much
better because javascript is better and
anything that can be written in
javascript should be written in
javascript and that's true because Jeff
Atwood says so and your mum smells the
other side says oh yeah well you're just
a back-end developer with no idea how
the web is meant to work you're so
stupid you don't understand inheritance
and you're scared of the Cascade
hahahaha and your mum's so fat she has
her own namespace
we've all heard these arguments
regardless of which side you're on
it doesn't really matter now I love
component based development I didn't
used to but I do now because it reminds
me of when I was a software engineer
writing Fortran and COBOL and 6502
assembler
in the late eighties yes I know I might
look 24 but I'm actually nearly 30 um
I'm talking mostly about react but we
could also talk this could also be
appropriate for web components which is
a spec that Alex Russell from Google has
been heavily promoting Google are really
behind this
I don't want you to read too much into
the fact that web components is pushed
by Google and it's an anagram of spec
own entomb that's just a coincidence I'm
absolutely certain but I love
component-based architecture because it
reminds me of when I used to write
little modules because the computer I
worked on could only have 8k in memory
at any one time and we could take
modules and share them and link them all
together
I like reusability because I don't know
about you you're all terribly
hard-working but I'm really lazy and if
I could write something once and use it
a thousand times in the future while
continuing to build the client I'm a
happy guy and I get to go to the pub I
like composability I like testability if
you have a small component it's easy to
do unit tests on it because a component
is a unit and I like shareability
I like to be able to give these two
people on my team or put them on github
so other people in the world can take
them because that's what we do we share
stuff of course you've all seen this
this gift about out about the
complexities of CSS and maybe this isn't
so true anymore now we have flexbox and
CSS grids
you CSS grids Jing gets $10 every time
you use them from the w3c but it's true
that CSS for components is a bit of a
pay
in the ass or ass depending upon what
you call your ass we can talk about that
later when we talk about toilet paper
the trouble with CSS four components is
everything's global you can't adequately
scoop your rules to a component easily
so Styles can leak or clash the order
affects the Cascade and when you're
pulling in lots of different components
that can easily become unmanageable and
give you surprises it's really hard to
make an adequate dependency system for
CSS also it relies upon markup structure
yes your HTML doesn't no need to know
about your CSS but often your CSS really
needs to know about your HTML structure
because you're using selectors that
might depend upon it and the problem of
course is if you break something it can
break silently when I used to work as
the front-end developer of a
governmental legal site in the UK before
the days of all the modern cool stuff we
have now it will be midnight on Saturday
when I would copy over CSS changes by
FTP it to the live server and then it
was absolutely terrifying because some
forgotten page in the hundred thousand
page CMS driven system would have
terrible font or the layout would break
and well that's why I look so terrible
that's why I look like this because of
all the stress of CSS breaking silently
and me not being able to test for it so
we've invented something called Bing CSS
in JavaScript this is probably CSS rules
but in some kind of object notation like
JSON rather than the squiggly brackets
we all love this isn't you
Netscape 3 had this thing called j SS
JavaScript style sheets you could only
use this JavaScript way
to style things in Netscape three and
they proposed it for the w3c the w3c
said whatever and like whatever whatever
whatever because it's three w's and so
the Netscape people then wrote a J ssnoa
CSS 2j sss converter which is why a
netscape if you turn javascript off
style was wouldn't apply with CSS but
anyway this thing j sss or as i like to
call it G's didn't really take off
terribly well so I've looked at some of
the the CSS in JavaScript solutions I
counted 59 competing solutions on
Michelle buteau Lee's list on github and
I have an opinion about CSS in j/s I've
looked at them and I can exclusively
reveal without risk of contradiction
that CSS in j/s is a sick perverted
world a sadistic Candyland in the sky
write it down there will be a test later
legal notice other opinions are
available
CSS is great I love it it's great
because you get fantastic ID support
whether you're using visual studio that
other thing webstorm jetstorm whatever
or sublime or Adam you getting loads of
ideas support for your CSS we get syntax
highlighting you get code completion
validation their CSS generators and
there's a huge community who know and
share tips about CSS it's also designers
anybody here a designer a few of you
well these are designers in the wild
drinking some flat skinny saw white
cappuccino frothy thing eating some
avocado toast lamenting they can't
afford a house and using Apple machines
and they're designing things and the
thing is of course these guys and girls
are really great at designing stuff and
because we all do responsive design now
we don't design in Photoshop comps we
design in the browser CSS is their tool
and we are making these expensive and
highly creative people abandon their
tool of choice to fit our development
methodology which is naughty of us and
it's discourteous and it's just bad form
if you disagree ask your designer to
open up your computer and choose the
fonts and colors that they want for your
operating system and IDE and then see if
that makes you more or less productive
and happy I'm happy to do this for you
myself you've seen my design skills I'm
pretty good CSS in JavaScript also costs
us you have to load a j/s library to
handle CSS creation at runtime you're
creating and modifying CSS at runtime
and if you're doing server-side
rendering and if you're not why are you
not doing it you're doing the CSS twice
once on the server and then squirting it
down the wire so I
been consulting now for seven or eight
months with wicks who are a website
builder and I'm advising them on web
standards because they wanted to solve
the CSS four components problem and I've
been helping them and giving them
fashion advice this is my colleague edo
edo rosen tile and he was asleep in our
smoking room in our tel-aviv office you
can see that the famous CSS blind is
above him and he was dreaming about a
solution and in his dream he wanted CSS
that was modular and only scoped to a
component but he wanted it also to be
dynamic he wanted it to be performant so
working at build time rather than run
time he wanted it to have all the
capabilities that CSS also gives us
because many CSS in JS libraries you
can't even do things like hover and he
wanted compatibility with all the
existing tooling and he wanted to be
able to customize components from the
outside too as well as have their
styling wrapped up with the components
well we came up with a single scalable
which is CSS four components
it's a preprocessor like less or sass
for styling components with typed CSS
basically what we're trying to do is do
for CSS what typescript does for
JavaScript so the first thing we wanted
to do was abstract stuff so that your
styling doesn't have to know about the
internal architecture of the component
so if you had a component from another
team or another another company and they
change something about the internal
markup structure your CSS won't break so
what we decided to do was have custom
States like like hover or focus we
wanted to be able to say if you are a
nav button in my gallery and it's in the
state of loading don't show it
it's a custom state like hover or focus
of course you can use those two but this
gives you custom ones and we also use
the pseudo element syntax here to
address things that are inside a
component without having to know the
structure anything that you give a class
name to is exposed as a pseudo element
that you can hang styles from without
having to know what the structure is or
if the structure changes your CSS won't
with type CSS you beget a superset we've
got inner parts of pseudo elements we
have custom pseudo classes type aware
dependencies IDE and build support and
we can optimize so we can do analysis at
Build time and do what we call rule set
shaking which is like tree shaking but
for rock sets
this gives us all kinds of useful
developer tooling like IDs like code
completion this is us using style in
visual studio with style intelligence
plugin and you can see that once it's
analyzed your structures it's offering
you all of the pseudo classes and the
internal stylings that you might want to
use which makes your life much more
productive this is how it works I don't
want to go to more deeply into the
syntax because I don't want to bore you
or waste your time or fall over that
thing again but I want to show you that
this syntax is entirely compatible with
CSS so we use this st4 styler ball
vendor prefix so that you don't get an
error in your IDE at Build time all of
these vendor prefixes are compiled away
and it compiles down transpires down to
static valid cross browser vanilla CSS
and of course you can mix stainable
compiler directives with absolutely
normal
CSS because we're importing from a
component we're giving it a default name
extending it and we can use all of our
CSS as usual we have a type system you
can define the gallery internals this is
saying this component can have states of
loading or empty to set them you have to
do this in JavaScript depending upon
when you know you're loading or you're
empty and you can do that by default you
do it with a data attribute but you can
customize that some more the status of
it at the moment is we have pseudo
elements and classes imports mix ins
with JavaScript or typescript theming vs
code extension that I showed you for
code completion etc coming up
integrations with more things and just
react and web pack and at the moment
we're working on pseudo classes with
parameters so you can say if this is a
column and its name is email make it
golden rod because golden rod is the
best color for matters we know this is
in other languages and we want to be
compatible with those my guys committed
this stuff to get up last week I'm not
actually sure if it's released yet but
it's in the repo declaration interfaces
so you can say for example you can style
any of the colors or the fonts in this
component but you cannot actually change
its layout so you won't break it if
you're laying out with grid or flexbox
for example more integrations and with
dogfooding it and battle testing it the
reason we've written this is because Wix
has had a problem with its websites that
it hosts particularly on mobile because
everything is done with CSS that is made
at runtime and sent down the wire to be
parsed in JavaScript it's very slow on
mobile this is much more performant and
within the next six months
you will see styler ball powering nearly
all of wix's 110 million websites that
it hosts at the moment another thing
we're doing is getting rid of lots of
JavaScript to layout we've done some
analysis and we've realized that nearly
all of the websites that currently have
some JavaScript to lay them out can be
done with CSS grid so there will be
about a hundred million Wix websites
using styler ball and CSS grid for
layout rather than runtime CSS in j/s
and rather than javascript it's going to
be a lot faster and we're battle testing
it for that this is a robust system and
it's going to be compatible with web
components and we're also keeping a
close eye on the Houdini spec which is
the ability to extend CSS with
JavaScript we've just committed that to
the repo so you can have JavaScript
macros in your CSS that will compile at
Build time into static CSS it's BDSM
license so you can get it right now and
try it out get it while they're hot it's
styler border IO and the repo is github
coms week's styler ball I want to
emphasize that I do not hate JavaScript
this is me having a beer with Brendan
Eich who invented JavaScript and how
come we Emily who invented CSS and you
can see that we're all smiling and none
of us hit each other at any point until
about the fourth or the fifth point and
I'm not a Luddite I used to be anti
frameworks when I was living in an ivory
tower of of web standards and then I
went into industry and saw how real
industry makes websites and it was
eye-opening to me I'm not afraid of
frameworks in Bucharest somebody had
written react wrong but I was not scared
I'm not scared of frameworks if you want
to use reactant bengi allure bone
strapped hub patch Jas
use it knock yourself out do whatever
makes your life faster and more
productive but remember that all of
these things are just tools they might
be well known tools but they are just
tools and using your tools well is the
definition of an artisan or craftsman or
craftswoman a worker in a skilled trade
especially one that involves making
things by hand
but I prefer this Japanese word any
Japanese people in the house good then
you won't hit me for mispronouncing it
shokunin means not only having technical
skill but implies an attitude and social
consciousness a social obligation to
work is best for the general welfare of
the people an obligation both material
and spiritual and I think that's what
we've been in danger of losing sight of
as we fight our holy wars
now I'm an HTML coholic okay this is uh
it's actually a brand of clothing in
Japan so they kind of looked very
weirdly at me at this department store
when I lay down next to it but I first
encountered the web in 1999 so instead
of talking about my employers product
let's talk about me let's talk about me
going me this is me a couple of years
ago okay this is me in 96 when I went to
work in Bangkok Thailand setting up a
school a primary school and a
kindergarten which I set up and ran for
a few years and when I was there is some
of my students it's really nice they
were married now and they invited me to
their weddings blessum when I was in
Thailand I got sick
basically I lost the use of my left eye
and my left leg and my arm and I went to
hospital because I had private medicine
and they diagnosed me with something
called mole
- boss chlorosis which is lots of these
in the brain and that was really really
lucky because in Southeast Asia
multiple sclerosis is a really rare
disease it gets more and more prevalent
the further north or south you go from
the equator so it's very big very
popular in Scotland Norway etcetera but
I was lucky because the lady who
happened to be the duty neurologist had
just done a year's work in an MS
facility in the US and because it's so
rare in Southeast Asia they couldn't
give me any english-language information
the only thing they could find was
Xeroxes from a medical textbook full of
encouraging photographs of autopsy
brains which are about you but it didn't
really make me feel better
but when I got out of hospital and
taught myself to walk again I went
downstairs from my apartment in Pratt
Nam in Bangkok and there was this thing
called an internet cafe so I went to
this internet cafe and I typed in
multiple sclerosis into Alta Vista which
was like Google but powered by steam and
black and white and it came back with
this julie's joint which is a global
support network for people with MS it
was founded in 95 by Julie hull up with
Julie Howell
when you're first diagnosed you may not
know anything about MS or anybody who
has it it can be a scary and lonely time
I created Julie's joint so that people
were living with this disease can get to
know others around the world to share
experiences and give each other support
and that was great
instead of autopsy brains I was talking
to people who had the disease had lived
with it for a few years it made me feel
better and taught me that I hadn't been
just handed a death sentence there were
people from the UK USA Australia Canada
Germany Sweden Switzerland rest of the
world etc but this blew my mind because
what I had here was a collective of
different people around the world with
different backgrounds different hopes
different experiences different kind
Computers this is 99 all coming together
to work together on something and it
made me realize that the web was where I
wanted to work so I went back to the UK
and set up a publishing company for web
professionals became a web developer
became deputy CTO of opera and now I'm
consulting for weeks because this opened
my eyes about the web
weirdly when I got back to the UK and
set up a book publishing company the
first book we commissioned was about web
accessibility and one of the reviewers
was a woman called Julie who was the
woman who set up that ms support site
that I found in Bangkok and we've become
good friends who we are going to see the
Sex Pistols here we are at a party for
the 10th anniversary of that web site
here's Julie with my daughter going to
an art gallery and I met her and became
friends with her through the web and it
made me think what what is the web it's
not loads of computers it's on loads of
computers but that's not what it is it's
certainly not clowns it's definitely not
a series of tubes this is what the web
is it sees African women it's this blind
guy in Toronto
it's these ladies on a bus that I
photographed when I was visiting
Bangladesh it's this lady in Korea that
I photographed it is these two farmers
in Thailand that I photographed it's
these guys that I found on a stock
images image
it's this man with Down syndrome on the
New York subway
it is these ladies on the beach in South
India that I photographed a year ago the
web is people and people are here there
are more people living inside this
circle than the rest of the world
outside this circle and that was fat
checked by The Washington Post Asia is
now four billion people I've counted um
by 2050 or 20 know by 2050 the
population of Asia will be 5 billion the
United Nations predicts China 1.3
billion people with a GDP growth of 7.7%
I don't know what the GDP growth of
Singapore is but in the West and in the
u.s. they would kill to have growth at
this level on Black Friday and Cyber
Monday in 2015 the last dates I have
figures for 2.9 billion US dollars
changed hands in the US on double 11 day
the 11th of November 2015 in China nine
point two billion dollars changed hands
total online retail spending in China
reached 307 billion in 2013 and is
forecast to grow at 20% until 2019 when
XI it should exceed a trillion the
numbers of startups valued at a billion
or over that's China
Africa is 1 billion people now by 2050
that will rise to 2 billion by 2100
which may be a little late for me but
maybe not for you by 2100 the population
of the world will peak at 11 billion
people five billion of them will live in
after
Africa has relatively good connections
now this is a map of the submarine
cables going into Africa you can see it
starts pretty small and then it's
getting bigger and they're getting
faster and faster connectivity but of
course submarine cables go under the sea
and they end up at the shore and Africa
is really really big so whereas people
on the outside the shorelines of Africa
have good connectivity people inside
don't and maps lie to us or release maps
that are done in the Mercator projection
Africa is really really really big you
can fit China the UK India the US
Eastern Europe in the landmass of Africa
so if you live here away from the coasts
internet access is slow and really
expensive landlocked countries play
higher prices for bandwidth in Africa
for instance being landlocked adds 232
US dollars monthly for fixed broadband
imagine I mean in a rich economy like
Singapore or the US or the UK my paying
230 dollars a month more for my
broadband would be a real bummer
imagine how prohibitive that is in
low-income countries like sub-saharan
Africa and as a safer mobile broadband
the difference is a hundredfold for
landlocked countries in Pakistan it's a
dollar 48 for a gigabyte of data a month
in South OMA and Princip it's a hundred
and seventy US dollars but the paradox
is people become richer when their
broadband becomes faster the employment
rate in connected areas relevant to
unconnected areas increased by 4.2 and
between 4.2 and 10% when fast internet
became available in most countries in
our sample the increase of skilled
employment was bigger for workers with
secondary or tertiary education but
who only completed primary school are
also more likely to hold down a job once
fast Internet becomes available but it's
not just about affordability despite the
fact that Africa has the lowest income
per capita of any region affordability
was only identified as the most
important barrier in one of the 13
countries at the GSMA surveyed network
coverage is not perceived as an issue
for most countries however mobile
broadband 3G or 4G still remains low in
Africa the biggest problem was a lack of
awareness or locally relevant content
and its lack of digital skills it's the
same in Asia a lack of awareness and
locally relevant content was the most
commonly cited barrier to Internet
adoption 50% of websites in the world
are in English but that's only spoken by
10% of the speakers in those countries
only 2% of the websites worldwide are in
Mandarin and 0.1% are in Hindi in Africa
7 of 10 people who do not use the web
say they don't know how to use it and 4
in 10 do not know what the internet is
and that's not just in emerging
economies in high-income Poland and
Slovakia one-fifth of adults cannot use
a computer in the States 41% of seniors
do not use the Internet
53% don't have broadband natural access
and 23% don't have cell phones this is
my friend Paul Arnett and he tweeted
this on Christmas Day he's doing tech
support we heard about that earlier me
on tech support what buttons are on your
screen my mom a hot water bottle and a
dentist's chair it's funny right but you
can see her thinking here the things
that we take for granted as obvious are
not a friend of mine called Sophia
Parvez does route just usability testing
in rural areas in Pakistan and she's
given me permission to show you this
video
I've edited it down but it's still
bloody painful this is a guy in his 20s
in Pakistan
he's a feature phone user he's been
given a smartphone and he's been asked
to google the name of his favorite
actress
two minutes 53 seconds
and he gives up at 3 minutes and 15
seconds of course the problem he had was
that his feature phone and Nokia have
physical keys he simply doesn't know how
to call up the virtual keyboard I show
you that because the next time you make
something that you think is incredibly
intuitive think of this guy he's not
maybe yet he just doesn't know how to do
it and of course not everybody has
trouble with smart phones this this
Cambodian boy whom I met on a beach when
I was on vacation in Cambodia
I don't speak any climber but he was
very interested in my Google Nexus 5x
within one minute of me miming
instructions he'd managed to take this
selfie of himself a photograph which
never fails to cheer me up when I'm
feeling a bit melancholy there's a
digital divide not just between the
wealthy nations and emerging economies
there's a digital divide in Africa
between poor and rich old or young ruler
urban and men and women and as a digital
divide in India when I landed in India
last year to do some press and TV work
the in The Times of India they announced
that rural mobile Internet users grew by
93 percent year on year but that 93
percent growth means that a staggering
nine percent of people in rural India
have any internet access at all that is
compared with 53 percent in urban areas
the World Bank in a report they
published early last year called Digital
dividends it's actually really
interesting and it's 370 pages I know
what has happened to my life the World
Bank have said making the internet
universally accessible and affordable
should be a global priority the web
foundation which was founded by Timbo or
certain berners-lee to you the web
foundation said in a
shocking blog post in Nigeria the data
needed to watch a two minutes of online
video a day can cost more than sending
your child to school for a month in the
words of the car parking machine in
Chinatown in my home city of Birmingham
change is possible and change is coming
there is a grassroot initiative called
fast Africa and they had lots of
activities across lots of African cities
in 2016 fast Africa they are agitating
for fair and transparent ICT taxes they
want governments and donors to step up
efforts agree on affordability and
affordability is defined as one gigabyte
of mobile data for two percent of
average income and I was actually very
pleased that yesterday the broadband
Commission of the UN has actually
adopted this as their target for
affordability fast Africa also wants in
public access solutions things like
computers in schools or community
colleges which are open to the public
after hours and making getting women
online a top priority the World Bank
online work can prove particularly
beneficial for women youth older workers
and the disabled who prefer the
flexibility of working from home or
working flexible hours in India women
are 62 percent less likely to use the
internet in the men in rural India two
percent of women use the internet or
actually no two percent of the nine
percent of people are internet access
are female the other 98 percent are male
but the paradox of this is we know that
the web empowers women globally in
non-agricultural employment women are
twenty five percent of the workforce but
in online working portals 44 percent of
the workforce are women when asked why
women said the ability to earn extra
money was not as important
the ability to work from home and work
flexible hours because worldwide of
course women bear the brunt of the
requirement to do child-rearing looking
after sick or elderly relatives
interestingly and sadly the biggest
disadvantage for women was payment is
not good enough which was much less of a
disadvantage for men suggesting that
just like everywhere else in the world
there is a disastrously unfair pay gap
between what women and men earn it's not
all bad news
I was recently in Kerala in South India
they speak a language called Malayalam
there it's the only language name in the
world which is a palindrome and spelt
the same backwards interestingly and in
Malayalam this says khuddam battery and
khuddam Bashi translates as prosperity
for the family it's an initiative by the
caralyn government interestingly Kerala
has the highest female literacy the
highest literacy the highest life
expectancy the lowest infant mortality
in India and it's consistently run by a
democratically elected marxist
government which is interesting but they
set up the could and battery project to
outsource IT services to cooperatives of
women from poor backgrounds 90% of those
women had not worked outside the home
before okay so I've given you all these
facts and figures which are pretty
pretty demoralizing I didn't swear do
not get me for the code of conduct I
said oath feet I just tripped over what
can you do you can make a progressive
web app I'm not going to go into what
they are particularly now because I'm
running over time doubtless you know it
is no coincidence that the best and
earliest progressive web apps have come
out of Asia and Africa Indonesia
Indonesia Kenya Nigeria India because
downloading a typical app on
an Indian network of 20 megabytes will
take more than 30 minutes and more often
than not just craps out and cheaper
Android devices are pretty low in
storage at Google i/o last year it was
announced that 25% of new Android
shipments only have 512 Meg of RAM and
very low storage space so if you have a
massive downloadable app even if the
user can actually download it it is
taking up space on their phone with
space that's limited the user is
comparing their personal photo
collection with getting your app we
didn't stand a chance said birdly in
there below with their blog post why you
shouldn't bother creating a mobile app
we didn't send a chance we're fighting
with both our competitors and other apps
for a few more megabytes of room inside
people's phones and our Geryon developer
that I interviewed a year ago said
Nigerians are extremely data sensitive
they sideload apps and other content
from third parties and they never update
them with PWS without the download
overhead of native apps developers in
Nigeria can now give a great and
up-to-date experience for their users
what else can you do you can simply
optimize your images in 2011 I had a
slight hangover it's a very unusual
thing for me but it was one of those
times and I'd read a blog post by Jake
and lots of developers had said it's
really difficult doing images because if
you send a really nice shiny image to
these new Retina devices on a three inch
square black and white Nokia screen it
has to be compressed down which takes
CPU cycles and uses the battery and
people are downloading far more data
than they actually need whereas if you
give a low resolution images otar if you
give a low resolution image it doesn't
show very well on the retina things now
you told me I can go on for as long as I
want there's only another 40 minutes
and you're fueling me now the average
webpage not websites not web app is for
Meg of which 1.8 Meg is images if you
can make your image is smaller with
responsive images you are using less
bandwidth I did a talk on responsive
images because I was one of the team of
handsome men who made the picture
element etc that's in all the browsers
now and a developer saw my talk and he
put into practice of things I've talked
about and then told in the next day his
website his web page had gone down in
size by 70% because that matters in
Germany in Germany to afford entry-level
mobile broadband for a month you need to
work one hour at average wage in the
States you need to work six hours at
average wage in Brazil you need to work
34 hours at average wage and if you are
sending down vast bloated images you are
making Brazilian people work harder and
that's rude liberal hand-wringing ahead
please guard the web as you work on it
it's a medium that has given you a great
sound of a living it allows you to come
to a nice aircon room and listen to
interesting people and listen to me as
well and it gives you a nice
middle-class life it's been good to you
make it good for other people preserve
it for example someone or something or
combination of people of things are
using YouTube to frighten traumatized
and abused children automatically and
scale and it forces me to question my
own beliefs about the Internet at every
level this is available on Amazon this
is an iPhone cover of a woman having a
armpits waxed of course this doesn't
actually exist a bot has posted this and
if you were foolish enough to buy it
then they would make it on demand and
send it to you you can also get this
rather nice iPhone case
of toenail fungus if you want to or more
regrettably and much less funnily you
can get this t-shirt made by a bot even
worse I was reading a really really
in-depth report about how fake news in
Myanmar has contributed to the ethnic
cleansing / genocide of the reinjure
Muslims access to the web is critical
but not sufficient so the World Bank the
full benefits of the information and
communication transformation will not be
realized until countries continue to
improve their business climate investing
people's education health and good
governance but we need to do this the
developing countries are home to ninety
four percent of the global offline
population and those people deserve the
benefits that we have realized from the
web if my hippie [ __ ] doesn't
convince you here's some numbers from a
big management consultancy group called
McKinsey an increase in internet
maturity similar to the one experienced
in mature countries over the last five
years creates an increase in real gross
domestic product per capita of 500 US
dollars on average during this period in
five years it took the Industrial
Revolution of a 19th century 50 years to
produce the same result you in this room
are the new Thomas Edison's you are the
new isambard kingdom brunel you are the
new Thomas Telford you are the people
who were building this for the next
people do it properly please remember
there are tens of millions of people in
Bangladesh Nepal Pakistan who cannot
afford a school textbook but a feature
phone with access to world reader is
textbooks there are people who cannot
afford basic medical care
we'll have to walk miles for it but
feature phone access and the web and a
copy of where there is no doctor in
their own language is medical care there
are people in horrible repressive
totalitarian regimes who might have the
wrong religion the wrong political
opinions whose only access to the
outside world is the web there are 25
you are there are 30 year old scared men
in a hospital bed
believing they've been handed a death
sentence and the web makes that better
do the right thing sorry for being
boring bye
[Applause]